I have never done we'd realize we've
never really done a rebuttal of The
Daily Show yeah Trevor Noah and if it's
just there's not a whole lot there John
Oliver I will say the guy does some
research he kind of has a pattern and
we've we've been able to pin it down now
but Trevor Noah it's almost entirely
conjecture and I think that's important
when looking at claims you can say
listen this is my opinion or I'm drawing
some kind of conclusion or analysis
based on the information at hand but
sometimes there are people out there who
just don't provide you with a whole lot
of information I think that's the case
here there's really only two claims that
we can verify but I think it's worth
examining because while the well the
hurt while the Hurricanes been going on
the storm has been going on and North
Korea launched a missile over Japan the
media is still talking about Donald
Trump
but talking about pardoning our payoff
because this is what's most urgent so
Trevor Noah obviously had a bid on this
and he was upset let's go to his first
argument as much as Sheriff Arpaio
presented himself as anti illegal
immigrants it turned out that he was
really just anti being a decent human
being if you talk to law enforcement
officers that have worked with this guy
they will tell you he's a thug and he's
an embarrassment yes
the man Trump pardoned is regarded by
many as one of the worst sheriffs in
America it's not really a claim is it
sick yes but you don't have to take
whities down middle eastern yeah you
don't have to take my I don't know how
to do this exact cent I don't know it's
also your mouth to do but don't take my
word for it here's Joe Scarborough then
back to me I agree um okay so he claims
it a lot of people say our pay Oh is the
worst sheriff in the country you you say
that and then you have people come on
the show who agree with you but if we're
looking at it objectively and I'm not
defending everything that sheriff has
done here crime dropped dramatically in
Maricopa County here's a chart so we're
gonna look at the main litmus test for a
sheriff I don't know if you're aware
about if you're aware of this but a
sheriff's primary duty is to reduce
crime I know I know
law law enforcement they actually do not
serve as community liaisons who are
yelling hands up don't shoot to go out
and make sure the aunt if I feel as
though they have a safe place their
primary duty is to reduce
right so I don't know I I don't know
again Trevor doesn't back this up at all
but he goes on to make some more I guess
sort of understand they make some more
unsubstantiated claims but I will say
there's some validity to this Arpaio has
made a name for himself by forcing
prisoners to live in canvas tents in
triple-digit temperatures cooled women
in labor to the bed his aggressive use
of stun guns overcrowding in his prisons
prisoners there died at an alarming rate
often without any explanation given
marche latino prisoners into a
segregated area with electric fencing
okay now first off um I'm not going to
defend all these actions the one now
some of those by the way are completely
unsubstantiated some of them have been
proven there were people weren't treated
necessarily very well for example they
were forced to wear pink underwear I
don't if your constitutional rights
especially considering that people who
are not citizens or even here legally
you're not violating Americans
constitutional rights you don't have
constitutional rights if you're a
terrorist or if you are an illegal
migrant that's an important lineage to
make because he goes on and say [ __ ]
violating American civil rights no
that's not the case but um again I'm not
defending all of his actions here but
it's important to separate the
personality that you have a problem with
and what he was actually being charged
with what he was actually what the
political witch-hunt was actually about
so here's something I find interesting
let's do an exercise here okay
concentration camps that's that's what
people were calling and he joked about
it
that was tongue-in-cheek because the
media type in concentration camps what
it was was he had huge camps and yes
bunk beds stacked three high with
illegal immigrants in his County okay
begs the question why anyone here have
an answer overcrowding yeah why do you
think he would be so overcrowded with
illegal immigrants that he has to put
them into a camp that people dubbed
concentration camps he's doing his job
as sheriff when he finds these people
when he encounters them and they are
here illegally and rounding them up but
the federal department when we look at
ice was not deporting these people we've
talked about that before we had
interviewed people on the show who said
listen the only difference now is that
Donald Trump has said okay you can do
your jobs and you can deport people when
you find them here illegally so this
brings us to the next claim from Trevor
Noah the one that actually we can verify
and now
abuses of power didn't just hurt the
inmates at his prisons right
they also hurt the taxpayers who had to
foot the bill during our pyo's tenure
between 1993 and 2015 cases involving
Arpaio and his office totaled a hundred
and forty two million dollars in legal
fees settlements and compliance costs
according to the Arizona Republic in
fact that includes two lawsuits over the
wrongful deaths of prisoners and tens of
millions in civil rights and
discrimination suits okay so the claim
is he cost taxpayers 142 million dollars
that's more than hundred forty-one
that's more than four look it up
actually the numbers closer 146 yeah but
here's the question
who cost the taxpayers one hundred and
forty two million dollars
the guy who is doing his job and
rounding up illegal immigrants who make
Americans less safe and of course as
they drain in the system into which
legal taxpaying Americans contribute or
the Department of Justice who went on a
political witch-hunt to charge him with
crimes of doing his job by the way in
that same time these supposedly
sanctuary cities who were not complying
with federal law nothing nothing they
were flagrantly disregarding the law
nothing happened there were no charges
brought and don't think that it wasn't
just oh so convenient for these charges
to be brought two weeks almost to the
day before
sheriff Arpaio's re-election you know
what I hate they're lumping all these
things together they're not giving any
objective facts in an alarmingly high
rate they're not saying anything he's
one of the worst in the country is there
a list of worst people in the country
for sheriff and then they say they spent
way too much what is over what 22 years
yeah and there's two lawsuits so you're
gonna say that we're bad yeah terrible
in 22 years and how are you never to
fight against the Department of Justice
yeah exactly you did it to yourself I
mean it's what we showed him we charged
him and he's fighting back you assaulted
him like you assaulted him automatically
I assaulted this man he came back and he
hit me with the hospital bill yeah and
they put compliance cost what is it what
is this I fractured your skull what was
this I want to see an itemized easily
see what was this was this caviar at the
hospital I call [ __ ] I think so we
can blame 142 million or a hundred forty
six million we gave you that one
I go back to completely unsubstantiated
opinions let's see the next one his
agency has been accused of pulling over
drivers just because they were Hispanic
so they could check their immigration
status and not just because of traffic
violations Wow
being Latino in that town must suck I'm
okay with it
well if you're illegal by the way if you
look at the staffing from from the same
Sheriff more Latinos I think than any
other county in the country I think he
has two grandkids who are a portion
Latinas relative so this is not a guy
who just hates people he meditated from
other color their skin the guy who hates
the apps that the the plight of illegal
immigrants and the crime that they bring
to southwestern American cities so I
mean this is one deal to yeah I mean if
you look at the crime I think it's
illegal immigrants have committed oh
yeah there we go we have the overlay
there 22% to 37% of all murders in the
nation well they make up three point
five percent of the population their
significant some people would call it
that and we get really upset about
racial profiling let me give you the
truth if you live in a southwestern town
or a border town if you live in El Paso
if you live in an area that's close to
the border and you hear about a lot of
crimes committed the police sketch
artist is gonna have a tough time okay
when you describe them that's the
reality if so if there was if there were
a gang out there right now committing
crimes and mass and it was the six-foot
to brown haired hazel eyed gang and I
got pulled over
I said officer what seems to be the
problem listen I'm just pulling you over
because you match a profile there was
another one of those senior members of
the 6-2 brown hair hazel I can you
knocked up and knock at a Lichter story
but you know what
first off seems a little redundant for
the title it seems needlessly long but
thank you officer I appreciate you doing
your job it would seem that people that
would have the most grievances would be
the hardcore brown eyes six foot two
criminals big point here illegal
immigrants yeah a lot of times they will
drop that part and just so he's blaming
all immigrants no he's targeting a
specific group of people that are here
illegally yeah and you know who's most
aggravated with illegal Latino
immigrants people who've come here
legally or illegally teen immigrants
scale it back one my mom's
french-canadian who came here legally
guess what she can't stand people who
happened not even hopping a wall by the
way people just happen to saunter on
across some unprotected land in El Paso
come here don't learn the language even
though she was French and she learned to
speak
English perfectly to give a taxpaying
contributing American citizen she gets a
little bit irked when someone comes over
here illegally doesn't sign the
guestbook and starts committing crimes
and record numbers there's a guestbook
so there's some people left read
legitimate grievances you're trying to
hold up your look at these victims yeah
there there are tons more actual victims
that we don't want to address why
because he can't buy their votes all
right let's see you next clip and now
here's what may surprise you all that
that all pyro did that's not why he
needed a pardon no those were just his
extracurriculars yeah it turns out his
full-time job is racism you know for a
guy who's not racist Donald Trump sure
has a lot of racist friends by the way I
do I do love that this shows how
paper-thin his argument was beforehand
he's like all of that is minor the real
takeaway here is he's racist I know what
surprises me there that you still have a
show 146 million dollars in taxes look
at this cruelty look uh yeah but the
real problem is he has racist friends
tells you that there wasn't really a
whole lot to base that previous case on
if he were hooking people up to you know
electrical wires and jumper cables
cables to their balls that would be
that'd be the lead that would in this
case the takeaway is that he's racist oh
because he has some racist friends
allegedly race his friends that makes
him a racist this is this is why Trevor
Noah is just and then by extension
Donald Trump as as bad as it gets he's
an absolute cancerous growth on the
testicle that his comedy because he is
some people erase the sets and racist
things it is the social justice warrior
comedy to a team and said that there are
things that we shouldn't say is
comedians he doesn't even support free
speech okay so if Donald Trump pardons
someone who has friends who are racist
yeah that makes him a racist okay Barack
Obama pardons terrorists Oscar Lopez
Rivera mm-hmm he pardoned [ __ ]
treasonous traitor Bradley Manning what
is it Chelsea Manning does that make
Barack Obama a [ __ ] slash traitor
I can see anyone can play this game and
we can do it a whole lot worse with your
guys only we don't we want to get to
some substantiated claims let's see if
you've got one more do you have one more
do you have something we can go with
remember how the three branches of
government are supposed to be equal well
convicting someone of
attempt is the one and only way the
judicial branch can put muscle behind
his decisions so when the presidents of
the United States steps in and pardons
someone's contempt conviction he's
essentially rendering the courts
powerless he is incorrect
so not the one and only when we talk
about removing muscle from the court
kind of like the courts removing muscle
from the American citizens to bear arms
as you look with four votes who believes
that private citizens had no right to
firearm ownership whatsoever so my
judicial activism may be as the Court
removed some power from the House and
Senate because I decided to act as
decided to simply create laws they're
not interpreting laws they creating laws
no this is the problem with the Supreme
Court and why it was so pivotal and why
you guys lost a lot of people who didn't
like president Trump voted for him just
because of all the traditional activism
that was occurring yet yeah you only
have Sotomayor in Ginsburg for so long
to say all right she believed is
granting him a pardon oh there you go
I'm kind of getting it now yeah um
better late than never
yeah because you know what that's
actually one of the few executive powers
expressly granted by the Constitution
I'll tell you what's not actually within
its constitutional authority as far as
an executive order an individual health
care mandate without an example that's
not there in the Constitution I believe
it's in there somewhere in the back know
allowing the IRS to target political
dissidents that's not their or even
taking your money too personally and to
GM / Chrysler yeah that's right it's not
under a theologian purview of the
President to take your money so that we
can continue funding the Kobalt hey if
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than $6 a month and you get
daily content no more clips Plus this
hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside